make sure to give us a like on facebook
facebook.com slash david pakman show
let's take some phone calls 617 830 4750
our next caller is from the 212 area
code caller what's your name and where
you calling from I'm con con upstate New
York I want to be the core engine I just
have a big question well okay if you
didn't want to be recorded you're
calling when we're taking live calls so
you're on the air right now if you did
not want to be on the air I would hang
up what your show on what time is your
show on on which channel I don't know I
all I can ever find is clips I can never
find the show right so the show is
available on two hundred radio and TV
stations that are listed at david
pakman.com slash stations the program is
on directv and dish network every night
at 11pm eastern time if you have directv
or dish network it's on a channel called
free speech TV and then the full show is
also available on youtube for our paid
subscribers and you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership what's with
otherwise on youtube is the clips that
you're seeing you can also get our one
our audio podcast on itunes or any other
podcasting service okay if you can see
how red iron in the face right now I
just feel really stupid I just wanted to
know so I could listen when it's
happening okay well listen that's great
we walked on listening so I appreciate
the call very much absolutely appreciate
that